uh let's bring you an update now on the
state of the economy and the latest
figures on the job markets have been
released within the last few moments
Caprice is here hi good morning what are
they saying yeah there's a lot in this
report we have data on employment and
unemployment but also vacancies
redundancies and wages and the big
picture is that the labor market is now
feeling the strain of low growth
sluggish growth High interest rates and
high inflation the unemployment rate
ticked up to 3.9 we thought it would
stay the same at 3.8 percent but 3.9
it's still pretty low by historic
standards the labor market is still
actually pretty tight and that's putting
pressure upward pressure on wages which
rose by 6.7 in the year to March that
was up from 6.6 the previous month now
sounds like a pretty chunky pay rise but
important to point out
that 6.7 is still considerably below the
rate of inflation which is in double
digits which means we're all getting
poorer and the bank of England won't be
happy about 6.7 because although we're
getting poorer it thinks at that level
it could still fuel inflation and it's
been aggressively raising interest rates
to try and Stamp Out inflation
economists thought that I would start
feeding through into higher unemployment
in a big way that massive surge in
unemployment hasn't quite happened yet
and it's a similar story across the
economy we thought would be in the midst
of one of the biggest recessions in
modern history hasn't quite happened yet
so overall the economy is more resilient
than we feared it feared it would be but
it also means that inflation might prove
to be a little bit more stubborn than we
thought it would be